Працювати з ідеями дуже цікаво. Дуже.
Культура — це те, що робить нас людьми.
Це наша здатність оперувати ідеями,
уявляти ідеї і проєктувати майбутнє.
Мистецький арсенал має величезний
потенціал залучати людей до культури.
Першочергово при створенні
будь-якої інституції є її концепт, її візії.
З Арсеналом було інакше:
спочатку виникла локація,
а потім постала проблема візії цієї інституції.
Дуже цікаво складалася ситуація,
суто урбаністично.
У самому центрі розташовувався
загадковий, закритий режимний об’єкт.
У 2002 році було ухвалено рішення
надати статус культурного
цьому військовому об’єкту.
Це інституція мультидисциплінарного типу.
Вона поєднує різні культурні практики,
різні жанри, різні підходи до мистецтва.
Його коріння в кількох конкуруючих концепціях.
Одна була пов’язана з музеєм
сучасного мистецтва від початку.
Друга ідея — з величезною національною експозицією,
яка мала б представити найбільші
скарби, що зберігають українські музеї.
В результаті Арсенал набрав своєї траєкторії.
З’явився Книжковий арсенал,
багато виставок сучасного мистецтва.
Арсенал зберігає теж пам’ятки
з археологічних досліджень,
які були на цьому місці.
Ця колекція розказує, чим була
вся ця частина Києва, не тільки сам Арсенал.
Яка її історія.
Мистецький арсенал розташований
на досить великій території.
Наше місце налічує близько десяти гектарів.
Арсенал має чотири поверхи і великі підвали.
З одного боку нові, з іншого боку історичні.
Це найбільш автентичне приміщення,
воно дуже мало змінилося
під час реставраційних робіт.
У підвалах є справжній лабіринт, багато приміщень,
окремих комор, які з’єднані між собою.
Тут можна справді заблукати.
Після остаточної реставрації, музеїфікації,
в цих приміщеннях будуть
розташовані експозиційні простори.
Ми досі є незавершеним об’єктом.
Інфраструктура Арсеналу
мала б виглядати трохи інакше,
і ми б бачили не лише перший,
а всі чотири поверхи.
Перший поверх мав би функціонувати
так, як він функціонує зараз.
Тобто як місце тимчасових виставок
і розмаїтих форумів.
Другий поверх мав би ділитися на два крила.
Те, що ми називаємо лівим крилом,
планується як постійна музейна експозиція.
Сподіваємося присвятити цю частину
Арсеналу сучасному мистецтву.
Оскільки Арсенал має мультимедійний характер,
в правій частині повинен бути
експериментально-театральний простір.
Третій поверх мав би бути
присвячений освітнім потребам
і місцем роботи команди.
Бо зараз команда працює в іншому будинку.
Стіна, яка відмежовує нас від Лаврської [вулиці],
має суто технічний характер.
Цей простір мав би бути
набагато більш відкритим,
щоб пішоходи могли
пересуватися по всій території
і бути включеними у паркову зону,
яка за планом мала б розгорнутися в цьому місці.
Одне з моїх найулюбленіших місць в Арсеналі.
Шкода, поки що ми не можемо
сюди запросити наших гостей.
Це фантастична панорама
на Печерські пагорби.
Тут згадується насамперед постать Івана Мазепи.
Місце, де був зведений
старий арсенал у ХVIII столітті,
пов’язане з діяльністю Івана Мазепи
та членів його родини.
Арсенал від початку будувався
як споруда прямокутної форми,
і тут здавна існувало таке
цікаве внутрішнє подвір’я.
Будівля старого Арсеналу
з’явилася на місці колишнього
жіночого Вознесенського монастиря.
Цей монастир був цікавим феноменом
київського життя ранньомодерної доби.
У цьому монастирі діяла одна
з найвідоміших майстерень золотого шитва,
черниці були високоосвіченими.
Певний час ігуменею, тобто очільницею,
була мати Івана Мазепи —
Марія Мокієвська у дівоцтві.
Є ще людський чинник, важливий,
щоб пояснити особистість і вчинки Мазепи.
У 1707 році він починає тут
за наказом Петра І, російського імператора,
на місці монастиря будувати Печерську фортецю.
Людина з великими амбіціями,
авторитетом, досвідом,
прощається тут зі своєю матір’ю, яка вмирає.
І починає руйнувати те, що він разом
з матір’ю тут розбудовував,
щоб виконати наказ російського імператора.
Цей конфлікт унаочнений в архітектурі довкола нас.
Бароковий Київ Гетьманщини
і структурована, правильна,
вимуштрувана, класична споруда старого Арсеналу.
Ми намагаємося відрефлексувати всі ці історії.
Історії глобальні, особисті, історії тих людей,
які тут ще нещодавно працювали,
і вибудувати свою візію цих подій та наративів.
Навіть коли подивимося на
напівзруйновані стіни старого Арсеналу,
одразу можна визначити вік
тої чи іншої цеглинки.
Жовта цегла, яка надає Арсеналу особливого,
бурштинового кольору, найстарша за віком.
Це XVIII — початок XIX століття.
Більш червонясті цеглини —
сліди більш пізніх епох і реконструкцій.
Це рефлексія до нашарування трьох епох.
Ці три епохи ми визначаємо трьома «М».
Монастир, мілітарі і мистецтво.
Сьогодні ми на прошарку гуманістично,
культурно спрямованому, мистецькому.
Дуже збільшились амбіції
на українській культурній сцені
після Революції Гідності.
З’явилося ґроно інституцій,
які мали оцю амбіцію бути новими,
інакшими, складними.
Функціонувати у найкращий для суспільства спосіб.
Хтось з них — суто професійні інституції.
Як УКФ [Український культурний фонд]
чи Український інститут книги.
Хтось з них є інституціями глядацькими:
Мистецький арсенал і Довженко центр.
Але великим здобутком була
можливість працювати інакше.
Арсенал — один з найбільш інноваційних
культурних осередків в Україні.
Таким чином він складає орієнтир,
а ці орієнтири дуже потрібні,
щоб будь-що просувалось.
Найпростіше робити щось,
що можна грубо назвати «клікабельним».
Сенс цієї інституції не про це.
Не про те, щоб спрощувати
до зрозумілого одного образу.
Ми маємо робити складні речі.
І намагатися донести ці складні речі
до якомога більшої кількості членів суспільства.
Це виклик, з яким мають справу всі музеї світу.
Зробити так, аби людині, яка вперше прийшла
до музею чи галереї, було цікаво і захопливо.
І водночас не розчарувати знавця.
Наш освітній відділ робить кілька форматів занурення.
Один з них — «роздуми при вході».
Це коли відвідувачі збираються
перед відвідуванням виставки
невеликою групою і говорять про свої очікування
з модератором з нашого освітнього відділу.
Описують, що, на їхню думку, вони побачать,
як вони розуміють назву виставки,
контекст і так далі.
Потім самостійно оглядають виставку
і наприкінці знову збираються,
щоб порефлексувати про побачене.
Це допомагає набагато краще зануритися.
Звісно, найвдаліший проєкт Мистецького арсеналу —
це Книжковий арсенал.
Який починався, фактично, з книжкового ярмарку,
а тепер є головною інтелектуальною подією року.
Принаймні в Києві.
Проєкт поєднує мистецтво, літературу.
Виховує культуру читання.
Це просто фантастично,
думаю, тут усі зі мною погодяться.
Коли ти працюєш над проєктами,
ти закохуєшся у кожний з них почергово.
Кожний здається тобі прекрасним.
Якщо ти вклав так багато зусиль,
то важко якийсь проєкт вважати менш цінним,
а якийсь більш цінним.
Я ділю для себе ці проєкти на лінійки.
Одна з них пов’язана з дуже вагомими
постатями в історії українського мистецтва
останніх тридцяти років.
Це ті постаті, які часто були недопоказаними,
недопроговореними,
недоописаними, недооціненими.
Починаючи від Олега Олусія.
Наша найнещодавніша виставка —
це Андрій Сагайдаковський.
Це постаті, які, можливо, не були
помітні на офіційному рівні попередні десятиліття.
Але мали величезний вплив на те,
як розвивалося мистецтво.
Друга лінійка інтригуюча.
Це проєкти пов’язані з українськими 1920-ми.
З великими постатями, які наче
всім відомі, але поверхово.
Не так добре відомі непрофесійному глядачу.
Наприклад, у чому саме полягало
новаторство Леся Курбаса.
У такий спосіб будується наратив
історії українського мистецтва.
Місія Мистецького арсеналу сформульована
як «сприяння модернізації суспільства».
Ми не маємо ілюзії про те,
що завтра ми всі змінимось,
почнемо сповідувати
загальнолюдські цінності.
Але маленький внесок,
щоб збудувати більш справедливе
та толерантне суспільство,
Мистецький арсенал може зробити.
Принаймні показати відвідувачам,
що ми можемо бути інакшими.
Ті люди, для яких важливий Арсенал,
які приходять до Арсеналу,
і це часто люди, які є читачами та глядачами
виставок чи вистав, слухачами концертів.
Чи ті, хто може взяти участь
у дискусії як слухачі або учасники.
Арсенал чудово цьому відповідає.
Арсенал може створювати багатомірне середовище,
яке не є лише середовищем розумного дозвілля.
Це середовище потужного розвитку.
Це те, що допомагає людям
щоразу трішечки зростати.
Мати трішечки складніший погляд на світ.
Я не уявляю собі цікавішої діяльності.